well hello rec nation its Greg Alba here
this is Alyssa crazy who is the fiance
of dan now crazy yo subby Seibert
no because dan is crazy for marrying you
because they're engaged he's crazy
who want to marry you I'm so tell Dan
I'm sorry I mean you're lucky Dan who
we're gonna watch the battlefront
straight hey they got released not long
ago an analyst is gonna kill that dog
for me mm-hmm I might kidnap it I won't
kill it I think you should kill it
it clearly cannot get its behavior under
control trade only barks on videos that
I feel I have to put up theirs teen
violence and so pretty
[Music]
[Music]
Wow you wish to see me sir the empress'
dead
I feel kind of bad for the Empire
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
new yeah
[Music]
[Music]
yeah friends who got the beta they're
loving the [ __ ] out of this game yeah
yeah that's cool it looks like a
gorgeous game
oh absolutely I'd expect nothing less
and I really do like the I felt pretty
bad for that what's your name commander
commander bad woman
commander Eden mercy oh yeah she's on
the Empire side she should take down the
rebellion you know I've seen a lot of
trailers for the previous ones and I
love Star Wars but I was never really
compelled to really get into it but I
could totally get into this this looks
amazing
I believe I really wanted to say it I
believe you say that cuz when you say
that you end up playing it I like how
it's you know a different side of the
story it's funny how like there's Row 1
and then there's the force awakens it's
new Star Wars trilogy where the main
character is a female lead and now we
get battlefront where you're playing on
the Empire side right and it's a bad
female lead I think that's that's Ray's
mom yeah yeah it's my theory oh yeah
I am mind blown right yeah the moment my
brain just won I just want you know 9
times out of 10 when I make a Star Wars
prediction I'm wrong I'm excited for
this because I believe this character is
part of like some part of the book
series of Star Wars I don't know much
about it but I believe she's actually
pulled from the books never read any of
the books so couldn't tell you but
that's that would be great if it was
yeah I think I get a lot more people to
actually read the books too yeah cuz it
kind of brings attention to this story
because the books need to be read Star
Wars is tanking right now and they need
to make more money
can't imagine how they can get out of
you know what do you think
battlefront does a really good job with
the previous games of bringing in the
new additions to the Star Wars universe
DLCs I actually really appreciate that
they're incorporating the newer ones
into this one I mean obviously there
because they're popular but I like that
from what we're seeing it's pretty
inclusive yeah well how like rogue one
was the semi linked have how like
episode 3 and then episode 4 like that
bridge there this seems to be the bridge
between Return of the Jedi and the force
awakens this campaign mode you'll be
playing on the Empire side but you're
gonna still interact with characters
from the rebellion from the good side I
saw Luke in there you see way in there
even see Maz Kanata whoever Lupita plays
normally shooters like this or any type
of fighting game like this I usually
only play when I'm like ready your place
and you guys are playing battlefront
I'll play with how to farm with you or
I'm over at Tony's place but Star Wars
is the type especially with what they're
doing with battlefront to where I would
want to play the campaign mode yes it
seems heavily involved in the story I
don't know if it's canon or not
regardless of if it's canon or not just
from this trailer and this is the only
trailer that I've seen from this game so
far is the only one yeah it's the only
only trailer what I know I know
i I've been traveling a lot you could
yeah and you're gonna kill that dog
wait apparently hope my neighbors watch
this video so they know how I feel about
their dog just leave a very
passive-aggressive note on their fence
yeah you should quiet that dog before
someone kills this one trailer does such
a good job of making this story seem so
important that's why I feel so compelled
to play it is because it's not just you
know sit down pick up a gun fight some
dudes like it actually has a very
compelling story that I would like to
know more about its elevating who's
never really played the previous
battlefronts yeah I heard the
battlefront when they relaunched it it
wasn't as heavily involved in story as
fans would have liked it to have well
there was an online and it was more I
hesitate to say competitive but I feel
like that's what they were trying to go
for yeah yeah yeah but I heard this one
they're really going out of their way to
make it a lot more story yeah which is
always a plus a brings in people like me
who are like yes I want to play that
people like you oh that's right
alyssa has gaming channel and she
streams on Twitch
is that why you're here
so hey subscribe to Alyssa a stream
every day
yes videos done Hey
[Laughter]